من مدينة نيويورك ، البطل الأمريكي المفتوح والأول في
العالم كارلوس الكاراز ،
يسعدنا جدًا أن تكون معنا ، شكرًا
لكونك معنا ، إنه لمن دواعي سروري
أن تكون أقل من 24 ساعة
منذ أن حان وقت استيقاظك في
مدينة نيويورك  وقام بالتغريد
قبل ساعات قليلة ما حدث بالأمس فقط هل
غرق حتى الآن وأن لديك
بالفعل بطولة كبرى وأنك بطل جراند
سلام وأيضًا
رقم واحد أو المصنف الأول عالميًا وأيضًا أصغر لاعب
في التاريخ يحقق كل  هذا
في
الوقت
الحالي ما زلت لا أصدق ذلك ،
أعني أنه كان
شيئًا رائعًا بالنسبة لي ما فعلته
بالأمس وهو شيء
حلمت به منذ أن كنت طفلاً ، لذا
أصبح حلمي حقيقة ،
نعم أنا حقًا  سعيد بذلك ولكن في
الوقت الحالي
ما زلت
لا أعرف لماذا
ما فعلته ، نعم ، نعم ، يمكنني أن
أفهم تمامًا أنني لم أفز بأي
بطولة لكنني أفهم أنك
عاجز عن الكلام ، لكن دعنا نتحدث عن نيك
فضولي أنه كان أول من فعل ذلك
توقع أنك ستفوز ب  تأكد من
تذكيرك أيضًا بعد الفوز ، هل
أوضح سبب اعتقاده أنك ستكون
الفائز
جيدًا ، آه
لا فقط لقد رأيت
أنه اختارني كفائز في
بداية البطولة
وأخبرني بالأمس نعم ،
لقد أرسل لي  الرسالة التي
قالها لقد أخبرتك
أنني أخبرتك في البداية ولكن أعني
أنه اختار
نفسي
هناك ونعم كان
هذا توقعًا ، نعم
على أي حال كان الكثير من الناس يراهنون
عليك
ولكن
أيضًا يقول الناس أنك نادال الجديد
الذي يرونه
كثيرًا  الطريقة التي يلعب بها فيك ،
هل ترى أيضًا أنك
مستوحاة منه كلاعب شاب
جيدًا بالطبع أتطلع إلى رافا
عندما كنت أصغر سنًا وبالطبع ما زلت
أفعل ذلك
[الموسيقى]
ونعم أعني
هذا أه هذا  هو شيء قام به رافا
مرات عديدة وأنا أحاول أن أفعل
الشيء نفسه
في هذه الحالة أنت تعلم
فقط أه
رافا ألهم الكثير من
الأجيال الكثير من اللاعبين
الشباب وسأفعل هذا أنا "
سأفعل نفس الشيء كما أسأله بالطبع
ولكن هل تشعر بالضغط جيئة وذهابا
مقارنة
أم
لا لا ، لا أشعر بالضغط
لأقارن نفسي بنالال ،
لقد
حاولت فقط متابعة ماضي الماضي الخاص بي ،
كما تعلمون ،
نعم ،
أنا فقط
لا أفكر في ذلك  هذا نعم ،
فأنت تعلم أنني أريد أن أتذكر
مثل أه مثلنا
بالطبع وأنت تنجح بالفعل
في ذلك أو بدأت بالفعل
قصة نجاحك بعد كل فوز ،
عادة ما تنظر إلى الحشود ثم
تشير إلى قلبك و  ثم رأسك
هو طريقك في الإشارة إلى
مدى قوتك عقليًا
وعاطفيًا حتى تتمكن من الفوز بهذا
النوع من الألعاب
نعم أعني
أن الجمهور كان
مذهلاً بالنسبة لي إنه
شيء مميز وبالطبع
هم دائمًا
ما يكونون دائمًا
أنت تعرف في قلبي وأنا
في رأسي أه في رأسي وبالطبع
أتذكر المشاعر التي أعيشها في
شمال روسيا في كل مباراة
تعرفها وبالطبع
شيء فعلته لهم
أنت كلاعب شاب
وبدأت للتو  ما هو شعورك حيال
الثلاثة الكبار f  سيطر إيديرر نادال
وديوكوفيتش على اللعبة لفترة طويلة
بشكل جيد ،
فهم أفضل ما تعرفه ،
أقصد البقاء على نفس المستوى القتال من أجل
الأشياء الكبيرة خلال ما يقرب من 20 عامًا
وهو شيء أريد أن
أكون وأريد أن أعرف
للعب هناك لسنوات عديدة عدة أسابيع
أه تحاول القتال من أجل الأشياء الكبيرة ،
إنه أمر
صعب حقًا ولكني سأعمل من أجل ذلك ،
ما هو التالي بالنسبة لك الآن هل بدأت في
التفكير في بطولتك القادمة أم
أنك لا تزال مبكرة جدًا  ما زلت في
مرحلة الاحتفال ،
نعم ما زلت مستمتعًا بهذه اللحظة التي
تعرفها الآن لدي كأس ديفيس
الذي بدأنا يوم الأربعاء أه
وسأذهب إلى
فالنسيا لأكون مع الفريق
دعم الفريق وتقديم دعمي لهم ،
كما تعلم ،
لن أفكر في أنني سأفكر
في ما يكتشفونه الآن ، لا
تحاول الاحتفال قدر المستطاع
والاستمتاع بفوزك الكبير على أي حال
بعد  المباراة كما شكرت اه على تويتر
peop  le من جميع أنحاء العالم الذين ظلوا
مستيقظين لوقت متأخر أو استيقظوا مبكرًا لمشاهدتك تلعب في الواقع ،
كنا في العرض من بين
هؤلاء الأشخاص وبقينا متأخرين بالفعل
في كل مباراة وكنا نتأصل
لك يا كارلوس لذلك نتمنى لك كل
التوفيق والشكر  شكراً جزيلاً لك على
وقتك اليوم وآمل أن يكون هناك المزيد من
البطولات ، شكرًا جزيلاً
لك ، شكرًا جزيلاً لك ، بطل الولايات المتحدة
المفتوحة والأول في العالم
كارلوس القرز
[موسيقى]